hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
this is Rono we've been shooting a bunch
of fun videos to make sure you go check
out her channel and subscribe if you're
not already
but today whatever like hey let's shoot
some videos I just hop on Amazon and I
start looking for silly things and you
found this it's huge
well I feel like everybody has done the
Easy Bake Ovens which i think are like
the coolest thing ever do you know how
many high tech ones they have right now
like they have them in like every color
they look like spaceships but I was like
we need something like cheesy that seems
like just strange and different found
this have you ever heard of Lalaloopsy
before I've seen it around but I'm not
really sure what it is they look like
just a bunch of cute doll so I looked it
up because I wasn't sure either and
apparently there's a Netflix show they
have a YouTube channel
they have dolls and toys and it's all
based around these little like rag dolls
and I thought oh my gosh this thing says
it's a real baking oven whoo what's open
this up I've got a very tiny little pink
pocket knife here today oh but I thought
it was nice and festive and pretty and
matched our theme go for it that's like
an exacto knife thank you there believe
it I gotta get one of those ones that
wrap my vegetables okay looks like we've
got some mix we'll set that off to the
side let's just dump it out okay oh wow
okay whoa whoa some stuff may fall okay
I'm ready I'm ready
okay this spatula is like the size of
you biggest spatula I have ever seen I
mean it's adorable it's actually cooler
than I thought I'm having a really good
time already are we have you done oven
how many watts
tell me false warnings on the back
there's been there's danger there's more
warnings than directions whoa
whoa we might need a tiny mixing bowl
let go like a spatula maybe okay I got a
little bit of baking spray pole spatula
we got it is something you should never
do is put things on a hot oven but it's
not a relevant greenies on that one
we're gonna evenly coat a pant let's
actually step to completely live oh is
plug in the oven and turn it on and
preheat for 20 minutes
preheat this is the smallest old cake
pan go for whoa okay you've evenly
coated in the whole entire table in my
damn Jersey own it ready to go you've
got to do this one oh we don't we're
mixing in here but that's okay it's okay
it's fine step three batter half of the
birthday cake mix okay and then two big
pinches and one pinch and a dash of
water in the mixing bowl okay but like
what's a - how big is a pinch and then I
pinch this and then it says two big
pinches and a pinch so that's two big
big give it one get any bigger than that
okay dude one more big and now a regular
pinch this is the same nicest remaining
job they're just safe inches perfect all
right
oh shoot they're trying to be cute this
is so silly
okay so this measuring spoon are the
pinches I smell burning something I'm
just not sure that not your hair oh it
might be me here let's put this over
here oh this is the big pinch and your
pinch is not this big you need to at
least put one more piece yeah but look I
think what it's saying is half of the
birthday cake is a few pinches and one
pinch
hate it it's so bad just let you guys
know the pinches are measuring spoons
it's code for measuring spoons yeah see
a John this you think because I'm oh my
god do you want to know I don't think I
do I'm not sure idea what let me let me
please it's a ages eight unless you know
they're really smart eight-year-olds
these days I know you you don't think
about that now it looks like a funfetti
cake and then use the oven spatula to
push it in okay it's a bake for 12
minutes my gosh we could shoot an entire
other video and the time then takes us
cake to bake this makes for 12 minutes
that's too much time oh this is like a
real mini cake I'm just gonna dump this
in here I think I might enter on this
side they got a little graphic I think
oh that my pinch measurements may have
been slightly off I mean this is the big
moment that we've really been waiting
for dun-da-da-da here this is this is
you can do the honors I want to see
what's happening you see what says stop
here it won't but it doesn't go in a
sarong again you can't wait wait I think
maybe wait I think that might be how we
there got it in there now you get this
out
I don't know hey you hold it easy peasy
oh it's here look is it yeah I it's in
there how long is this thing completed
oh it's kinda needs to go back a little
I overdid it so there we go perfect just
jiggle it into the see the little hatch
all I see it oh it's in there
it smells like burning plastic like I
wonder why how we're gonna get that
thing out of there I'm concerned but
that's alright okay
separate mixing bowl we are gonna
combine frosting mix one pinch and one
dash of water you
he's brain I don't think we we don't
need is great you might have hit the
spray very far away oh yeah I think I've
broken actually the lids come on drop
the spatula oh sorry
Justine I gotta worry about cleanliness
in our kitchen
don't worry it's only gonna touch the
pan you know the food we didn't even
wash the pan so first of all this
clearly is not something that we should
even eat we didn't it okay mix still
dissolved it looks really good I'm gonna
get that in there mmm want to touch a
little warm yeah Baker's you think
that's like your penis is disgusting me
that is a good consistency it's real
thick this consistency is of kind of
like a cookie icing I'd say how the
royal icing and that looks more like a
frostings gross
Oh oops I think I'm gonna happen I think
I'm gonna put too much in now that's
turning sludge nail oh shoot oh no gosh
Chucky I'm just gonna do it yeah okay
something Oh what does it taste like
lemon tastes like plastic rolling a
little bit yeah very very plasticy let
me see oh yeah I was hoping for a lemon
yeah yeah I think we have high
expectations for something of this
caliber I mean did I just take it out or
like what do we do like it's gonna be
hot I don't know how to get out of the
oven
Justine when you look in here I think
you just got to shove it through like I
did it says peek inside to make sure the
metal doors are closed we did and there
you have it a shook ha-hey out of the
oven yeah Cheryl the ovens coming away
can't catch it cuz it's gonna be hot
well just get him in get him in I don't
have a mitt we'll just get a box hold
two bar I'm gonna do this so they're in
a bluff so I'm gonna do this oh no do
you think you don't know oh no it's a
don't push past here wait you push the
whole thing it's been there it's gonna
fry it's gonna catch on fire
right I got a plug
no I don't think our cake was done
either not strong enough
Siri shut up Oh Oh Spanish oh so dark
yeah something mammal something move a
little here yeah yeah that's not long
enough
I'm scuse me miss onk we're going to
catch on fire extinguisher just in cases
it's okay we're okay let me get I got
some stuff here
oh god I don't even think it was done
baking wait if it's already on the other
side it is yeah look oh she's no because
my bra other cake everything he's
probably melted to the top I cry every
time
chopsticks little nice big knife a
thingy I got it all we can't get it and
gotta save the cake honey miel I'll
admit I admit I got so upset I just okay
we'll just Dean these are my holiday
mints oh okay here here take a holiday
no now we lost the cake here I'll shake
it out
yeah no okay I got this now guys this is
unplugged by the way I just want to let
me know it is unplugged it's stuck oh oh
it's really stuck okay wait okay
ready for this is look at this that's
stuck in there oops
but you know what as long as it's stuck
might as well just jam it in there okay
man Aaron we just gotta get the cake is
it out no did you see it
yes I sort of see it hold on wait one
second one second a lot of things went
wrong
oh no oh no where'd the rest of it go I
thought we were gonna we could do this
one really easy oh there we go
what's you're you you're showing with
the holiday mitts
let's put icing onto anyway it is very
is it hot here put on your mitt for a
little bit of that on the top perfect
perfect
and spread it evenly maybe we can cover
the little holes of the cake yeah no we
need sprinkles
oh you're right careful they're getting
inside the oven in our cooling chamber
I'm just gonna they do have hole I don't
think we're ever gonna be able to use
this again I think this is a vented yep
yeah though I think we need more more do
you want more sprinkles you're getting
again this looks something like
something like I don't you oh wow it's
really warm I mean this entire thing was
baking that smells like burnt yeah it
smells like burnt plastic buon appetito
Villiers treat ourselves treat yourself
right right
yo sell of this tank hmm hold on I have
two fifties and I think I just cracked
[Music]
yeah well apart
okay the cake is not bad it tastes so
bad look I just want to got a taste of
it I mean now I cracked a tooth and I'm
going to food poisoning it looks so cute
though I'm super tolerable this tastes
so this is disgusting me but why it's
because of the recipe do you have the
aftertaste has a really strong
aftertaste I I do have to be alone oh my
gosh it's got a very strong aftertaste
it is rancid what would be the flavor of
the aftertaste I honestly don't know but
it's really bad like it tastes like this
melted I considered that this was gonna
be something easy and I was like wow we
could make cookies after this no we have
cookie oh they have cookies but we can I
cannot I cannot bring myself to even
know that that look like little buttons
well guys that's it thank you so much
for watching make sure you guys go check
out ROS channel we've done so many fun
videos
oh my gosh we've been having a blast but
this is the I forgot what was even
called lala-lulu
see Lalaloopsy oven and to be honest you
know I had pretty low expectations and
this is actually better than what I
thought was gonna happen so what we did
okay we did okay all right that's it oh
[Music]
I'm trying to think of a scale from like
we did really bad that we did excellent
I was like yeah we did something it's
bad it's pretty gross we did something
we did something
[Music]